[Music]
on this Saturday night does Canada have
its first case at the new coronavirus a
patient is in isolation in a Toronto
hospital health officials are actively
working to ensure that we identify
everyone this person was in contact with
as the global medical community
scrambles to stop the spread Peter
Mackay's fight for the top conservative
job together will expand outward that
big blue tent is he the one to defeat
Justin Trudeau Plus Trump's legal
defense trying to prove the president
didn't abuse his power and why the sales
of suds are falling flat
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news in
Ontario the provinces chief medical
officer is investigating a case that may
be linked to the new corona virus Global
News has confirmed the presumptive case
is at Sunnybrook Hospital in Toronto
health officials have yet to confirm the
case because they have to wait for
samples to be tested at the National Lab
in Winnipeg our Mike delay is following
the latest developments with the case in
Toronto Mike health officials still have
to confirm if it's an actual case but
what signs seem to be pointing to this
new virus well Robin a few things line
up number one the man traveled from
Wuhan which is at the epicenter of this
crisis and scientists have already
mapped this virus and developed a test
to be able to determine who has it now
they're confident enough with this man
that they are trying to retrace his
steps and get into contact with anybody
he may have come into contact with
health officials said it was inevitable
that Canada would have a confirmed
coronavirus case soon well late Saturday
afternoon it was announced that a man in
his 50s had flown out of Wuhan on the
21st arrived in Toronto on the 22nd and
was in Sunnybrook Hospital with symptoms
on the 23rd where he remains in stable
condition the patient was detected and
immediately put in isolation lab tests
were conducted and at the earliest signs
of a presumptive positive case Toronto
Public Health launched extensive case
and contact management to prevent and
control further spread of the infection
those who are in closest proximity to
him have put themselves in
self-isolation as a precaution it speaks
to how quickly the virus is spreading
around the world and why China is
scrambling to get it under control a
1000 bed hospital is being built in six
days with another on its way
in an upbeat and flashy show of strength
Chinese news anchors urged those
affected to strive on
however the streets tell a different
story they should be filled as China
celebrates the new year but tourist
attractions like the Forbidden City
Great Wall and Shanghai Disney were
closed
it's that mixed message that has
residents in Asia concerned but what is
in what isn't true
we've seen some ambiguous reports coming
out of the mainland what is certain is
that China has taken some unheard-of
steps to control the disease with a
lockdown affecting a 48 million people
in a travel ban covering 15 cities in
who by province we've never seen a
travel ban like this before so it's not
clear how effective or ineffective this
will be so far the World Health
Organization has decided against
declaring the outbreak a global
emergency yet it's clear the virus is
spreading with cases in several Asian
countries as well as Australia the US
and France where masks are now in short
supply and while Canada can be added to
that list
officials say the world is better
prepare this time already scientists
believe they've traced the origins of
the virus to a seafood market in Wuhan
which also sells live animals and while
the incubation period makes it difficult
to screen potential carriers at airports
an accurate test has already been
developed to determine if a sick patient
has been exposed we have the full
genetic makeup of the virus that's
causing the disease Public Health
Ontario have been able to develop a
rapid accurate diagnostic test Mike
we've talked about how inevitable was
that Canada would be hit with this virus
what is the risk to Canadians at this
point well officials maintain that the
risk is low even though that this virus
is more contagious yet less deadly than
SARS the man in question wasn't in
Toronto long enough very long at all
before he started showing symptoms he
then was taken to hospital where he was
put into isolation and everybody came to
contact with within his
own household have put themselves in
self-isolation but it but considering
what is happening in China officials are
trying to you know be positive yet they
are certainly not taking anything for
granted
robbing micro Li in Toronto one of the
most prominent conservatives in the
country former cabinet minister Peter
MacKay has officially launched his
campaign to lead the party
he's kicking off the race where he
started his career in federal politics
twenty-three years ago his home riding
in Nova Scotia McKay has deep roots in
the party but it won't be a smooth ride
to the finish line
as David Aken explains he'll have to
unite conservatives across the country
and convinced them he's the best one to
take on Justin Trudeau Peter MacKay is
one of his party's co-founders one of
its favorite sons though his own
six-year-old son appears to be on the
fence and he said well dad I'd vote for
you but I don't know who else is running
it's that easy charm that Mackay fans
think will help him win the jobs the
party's other co-founders Stephen Harper
once held party leader and prime
minister together will expand outward
that big blue tent with strengthening
its solid poles of conservative
principle with other big names like Rana
Ambrose refusing to run Mackay is the
easy front-runner in this race picking
up endorsements from Conservative MPs
from coast to coast he's going to be
addressing the concerns that we have in
Western Canada I'm a prairie boy I'm a
farmer I want to make sure that he's
hearing our voice but I know that he
spoke specifically took aback as well
and when you look at every region of
this country you have so much to offer
and he wants to unleash that potential
and we want to win the next election so
we're gonna be looking for the candidate
who can best build a coalition across
Canada but also advance Alberta's
interests and we know we can't advance
Alberta's interests unless we have
strong national government and we win
the next election McKay will have some
challengers including Aaron O'Toole who
finished third in the 2017 race that
Andrew Shearer one
O'Toole and Ontario MP released this
video today no one says anything in it
but his campaign says that's the signal
that he is going to run with a launch
event to be held Monday in Alberta and
this will be the tricky balancing act
from McKay O'Toole other leadership
candidates the leader of course has to
win over the party's base mostly Western
and rural but to win a general election
that same leader has to beat the
Liberals to those swing voters and those
voters are mostly eastern and urban
Robin David there are still deep
divisions in this party for example
social conservatives and their stance on
same-sex marriage and abortion how will
those divisions affect the race what the
vast majority of parliamentary
conservatives say that you know arguing
about abortion is one thing but any
perception that the party is anti-gay or
rollback same-sex marriage you know that
is going to be fatal at a general
election in fact a potential leadership
candidate who said last week that being
gay was a choice was roundly and loudly
denounced by by McCade by ron Ambrose
and by others but I think one of the
more interesting divisions this party is
gonna soon discover will be on climate
change
there are many conservatives mostly in
Quebec and Ontario who want a more
aggressive conservative climate change
policy in order to attract votes in that
part of the country that is going to put
them in conflict with conservatives in
the West who broadly believe that the
focus ought to be on supporting energy
industry workers instead Robin David
akin in Ottawa the state of emergency
has finally been lifted in st. John's
eight days after a monster winter storm
paralyzed parts of Newfoundland
businesses and services were able to
open their doors again classes are set
to resume Monday but the cleanup is far
from over a 24 hour parking ban remains
in place for areas outside of the
downtown area and the city is offering
free public transit for the next two
weeks in an effort to keep cars off the
road so crews can clear away all that
snow and RCMP confirm they found the
body of a man who went missing during
that storm the remains of Joshua wall
were located today
the 26 year old left his home in the
area of roaches line to walk to a
friend's house during one of the worst
blizzards to hit the province the
official search was called off earlier
this week but family and volunteers
didn't want to give up and continued the
efforts 22 people have been killed and
1,200 injured following that powerful
earthquake in Turkey this dramatic
footage shows a distraught woman being
pulled from the rubble nearly 17 hours
after the six point eight magnitude
quake struck the eastern part of the
country on Friday it's unclear how many
more could be trapped in the debris
nearly 230 aftershocks have been felt so
far canada is sending members of our
armed forces to help australia gain
control over those massive bushfires
a plane with 15 members will be deployed
to a military base near Newcastle in
hard-hit New South Wales
its primary function will be to deliver
fire retardant from the United States
the team will also provide airlift
support over a five day period this is
the first military flight being provided
by Canada this fire season 171 Canadian
firefighters have been sent to help so
far coming up on global national
Washington turns its attention to Donald
Trump's defense stay with us
you
after three days of arguments from
Democrats Donald Trump's lawyers have
plunged into their defense of the u.s.
president
it's a rare Saturday session of the
Senate impeachment trial the president's
lawyers argue he should be acquitted of
abuse of power and that he did nothing
wrong
when he asked Ukraine's leader to
investigate political rival Joe Biden
here's Jennifer Johnson presentation of
the case for the president for the first
time the stage belonged to president
Trump's lawyers their chance to formally
defend the commander-in-chief for White
House lawyers arguing the president
should be acquitted when you hear the
facts you will find that the President
did absolutely nothing wrong house
managers have already argued the
president abused his power by pressuring
Ukraine's president Volodymyr zolensky
to investigate Joe Biden while
withholding military aid and then
obstructed Congress's investigation but
the president's defenders say zalenski
denies there was any quid pro quo
president Solinsky said he felt no
pressure the house managers tell you
they know better the White House legal
team poked holes at the Democrats case
saying they ignored information from a
key person on that Trump szalinski phone
call Lieutenant General Keith Kellogg I
heard nothing wrong or improper on the
call I had and have no concerns the
president's defenders say this case is
an attempt to get him out of the White
House they're asking you to remove
President Trump from the ballot in an
election that's occurring in
approximately nine months
Democrats deny that and say this was a
weak start to the president's defense
there are gaping holes in their
testimony the Senate next week we'll
take a pivotal vote on Democratic
demands for testimony from top Trump
aids but Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
is still not saying if there will be any
witnesses at the end of the day I think
that goal of Senator McConnell is to
make sure that no witnesses are called
no evidence is brought before us
President Trump was not happy his team
began its case on a Saturday morning
calling a death valley in TV but his
lawyers say their two-hour presentation
was just a sneak preview and they'll
continue their defense Monday robbing
Jennifer Johnson and washing
thanks Jen tonight new audio from 2018
suggests the president wanted to fire
marie ivanovitch at the time she was the
US ambassador to ukraine the recording
is reportedly from a dinner party in
washington a year before you voinovich
was fired on it you can hear Trump
speaking to love Parnas a former
associate of trumps personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani you take over the biggest
problem there I think where we need to
start is we gotta get rid of the
Ambassador is she still left over from
the Clinton administration where the
ambassador were Ukraine yeah cheese is
basically walking around telling
everybody wait he's going to get a peach
take her out okay do it the recording
contradicts the president's statements
that he did not know --left Parnas a key
figure in the impeachment case against
trump ken Facemash stopped the corona
virus from spreading still ahead an
expert's advice on infection protection
you are watching global national as we
mentioned the new corona virus is
spreading quickly Global News has
confirmed a presumptive case at
Sunnybrook Hospital in Toronto
scientists and specialists are working
to understand its symptoms and severity
our Donna Friesen spoke to dr. Michael
Garden a specialist in infectious
disease about what we know so far about
the corona virus here's part two of that
conversation based on your knowledge of
how these things can spread do you think
that we're in the middle of this or just
on the cusp and it could spread much
more widely i I think we're still in the
early in the early stages of this and
the coming few weeks are really going to
tell us whether this virus so-called has
legs and really starts to spread or
whether this is like other brought other
outbreaks we've seen with corona virus
where you get to speak about you get a
peak of activity and then it fades away
for maybe forever or maybe for months or
maybe four years and then sort of pops
up again we're seeing that with MERS
right where we've had intermittent cases
going on for years now this may end up
behaving very very similarly to that but
we won't know that until you know the
next few weeks play out so we see a lot
of people across China wearing face
masks now is that an effective way to
avoid getting it and prevent spreading
it you know the face mask thing face
masks likely do something but the trick
is you have to be very consistent
wearing them you can't be mucking about
with them you have to wash your hands
regularly as well so it isn't the
ultimate sort of strategy it's not going
to protect people as much as you might
like it to protect face masks can also
be very helpful if somebody is sick and
they're wearing it it can actually it
can actually prevent them from coughing
organisms on to somebody else so both
people who are well and people who are
sick it may have a role well what is the
best way do you think for people
watching this to protect themselves if
they're worried about it basically the
same advice that we've been giving ever
since SARS still holds true so it's
frequent hand-washing alcohol gel works
very well if you're sick don't go around
other people and if other people are so
around you try to stay away from them
but really beyond that there is no
vaccine there is no treatment for this
so it's basically trying not to get
infected with the virus and not everyone
who contracts this virus is dying from
it should that be some comfort to us
absolutely I mean you have to think that
right now the mortality rate in this
virus is between 2 and 3 percent but we
also know early on and outbreaks we're
only detecting the really serious cases
and so modeling studies have already
been done that suggests that there's a
much larger population of people who do
not have a lot of symptoms if that's
true then the mortality rate of this
virus is actually far less than 1% and
it starts to look more like our regular
seasonal influenza again we're not going
to know that for several weeks until we
do more studies but already this virus
is less virulent than MERS and it's less
virulent than SARS and I actually take a
lot of comfort in that dr. Michael guard
I'm a specialist in infectious disease
thanks you're very welcome
still to come on global national ailing
sales the trouble brewing for beer
here's an unusual sight for classical
music fans in Munich a small crowd was
treated to a vertical piano performance
60 meters above an area that will soon
become a new concert hall the pianist
was hoisted up by construction crane as
part of the quirky out-of-the-box
festival the Swiss artist has been
performing this musical balancing act
since 2013 are you still working through
a dry January or have you already broken
that resolution it might explain why
alcohol sales across Canada and the US
are holding steady but as different
libations heat up the market fewer
consumers are reaching for a cold one
Reggie Cecchini explains why the bar
needs to be raised when it comes to beer
every decade has its signature cocktail
but old reliable beer has always stood
cold and proud as the drink of choice
we're always gonna be competing with one
another but his new generations come of
drinking age their demands follow and
that can cause a stir in the beverage
industry they're much more mindful of
what they're drinking so the Brewers
have to meet that consumer where they
are beer still outpaces all other
alcoholic beverage sales but has
struggled in recent years as consumer
choices expand in Canada less expensive
or value beer sales are down 9% over the
last decade while in the u.s. consumer
spending on domestic beer was down more
than 4% in 2019 falling flat to premium
and imported suds people trading up
where they'll be willing to maybe drink
a little bit less but spend a little bit
more to kind of get the experience that
they want trendy spiked shelters with
far fewer calories are also in a race
for the consumer we can still get our 5%
ABV but all of a sudden we can do it
with you know one carbon 100 calories
this offers a really great opportunity
to fit within this mindset that we can
have our cake and eat it too but it
isn't just bubbles that Brewers are in a
battle with I like to say that we're in
a golden age of whiskey top-shelf liquor
sales are soaring with more than 20
billion in sales across Canada and
u.s. today's consumer really doesn't
like to buy things what they like to do
is buy experiences a cocktail is as much
ceremony as it is having a drink
domestic beers once dominated the scene
but spirits and Seltzer's have gained a
strong following watering down beards
share of the market now Brewers are
being forced to navigate a hazy path
with marijuana sales added to the mix I
think the jury is still out on the
impact of marijuana on beer certainly
we'll be learning from our cousins in
Canada but that lesson could offer a
harsh reality one study shows that in
2019 one year after marijuana was
legalized in Canada beer volumes fell by
three percent but industry experts
aren't ready to wave a white flag
there hasn't been any strong indication
quite yet but they're going to be you
know diluting the the potential of sales
beer has been around for more than 5,000
years which provided plenty of time for
competition to catch up putting
breweries on the spot if you innovate
you can compete and I think that's where
we're going the sobering reality for an
industry looking to keep up with
changing tastes regi Cecchini global
news washington and that is global
national for this Saturday I'm Robin
Gill tonight your Canada is New
Westminster BC we would love to see your
corner of this country so email your
pictures to viewers at global national
calm thank you for watching and have a
great night
[Music]